also wirklich nur ganz ganz ganz ganz
ganz ganz wenig nehmen und dann läuft
das schöner drüber moment mal ich hab
noch nie vorher in irgendwie du alkohol
getrunken
ich hoffe ich hier jetzt kein hey dafür
manchmal dringlich auch alkohol aber nie
zu viel
[Musik]
hey leute was glaubt willkommen
ich musste dann erstmal ein bisschen
diesen tische testen
leute was geht ab ich hoffe natürlich
euch jetzt gut ihr fragt euch sicherlich
die wand darf nur weiß sein so schon
besser ihr fragt euch sicherlich gerade
herr robuste da jetzt haben wir noch nie
vorher gesehen gleich erklärt euch mal
schnell also eigentlich sitze ich in
meinem alten zimmer also hier bei meinen
eltern ich habe mich immer ein bisschen
darüber aufgeregt immer wenn ich hierbei
konnte ich keine vernünftigen videos
drehen oder hintergrund einigermaßen
klar gegen deswegen richtig mir jetzt
nach und nach dieser ecke
wir haben eine weiße wand im regal da tu
ich meine ganzen bestellungen und so was
eben bestelle einfach rein
das heißt dass wir hier so meine video
ecke und ich habe mir einfach diesem
tisch gekauft um halt möglichst viel
quatsch zu machen und irgendwie auch nur
50 euro gekostet also falls er mal
kaputt gehen sollte das auch kein
beinbruch
ja und dann darf ich euch ganz herzlich
begrüßen hier zu einem ersten video mit
dieser location also leute jetzt fange
aber auch an ich habe bock und ich hoffe
dass wir das auch tun sagt ey mache auf
jeden fall mehr papst davon
dann gibt er gerne jetzt schon mal
daumen nach oben wenn ihr sagt das war
uns nicht genug mache auf jeden fall
weiter mit dem format ich hab das ganze
nicht erfunden sag ich mal also es gibt
in deutschland schon irgendwie so ein
wissens video darüber aber ich hab kein
video gefunden wo sich wirklich jemand
hinsetzt und das dann auch ausprobiert
in amerika gibt es das zwar aber in
deutschland noch nicht und deswegen bin
ich mal wieder
falls ich mich nicht irre ist jeder
mensch pro tag 1000 werbung ausgesetzt
das heißt egal wo er hingeht irgendwo
ist ja immer werbung hieß werbung da es
werbung hier ist ausnahmsweise keine
werbung dass werbung da als wären da ist
werbung es ist ja überall werbung
heutzutage und heute geht es um essen
sex wie man in der werbung eigentlich
verarscht wird also wie die werbung das
ganze viel leckerer aussehen lässt als
es
mich ist das hört sich jetzt erstmal gar
nicht so interessant an ist es aber ich
hätte über sprechen und genau deswegen
mache ich jetzt auch diese video ich
habe mir für die erste folge vier
verschiedene beispiele rausgesucht und
dafür brauchen wir auf diese ganzen
sachen die wir haben wir haben hier die
sahne rasierschaum kleber spülmittel
bierbaum flechsig aus der luft weil ich
die selbst gerne auch sogar danach essen
würde von natürlich sagen will aber gar
nicht angefangen direkt man mit dem
ersten hack und das ist dieser hier ist
wenn das mal kurz ein und zwar sind ja
früchte in der tv werbung immer so schön
glänzend aus also so richtig frisch wenn
man die dann in echtzeit also ich habe
jetzt für das beispiel köln erst mal
gefunden die wachsen grad ja nicht dass
ihr sind so xxl sollte aufgehen die
glänzend weiß vielleicht ein bisschen
wegen dem licht aber es sollte man ganz
einfachen trick geben und der steht hier
ich spray diese frau ist einfach mal
voll mit der eu also das ist ganz
normales im herren d und dann schauen
wir mal was wir dafür ein effekt
erzielen können
[Musik]
und da kann man wirklich direkt sehen
das ist schon krass also diese hier
sieht so ein bisschen veraltet aus und
die hier komplett frisch richtig rot
strahlend ich weiß war 0 aufwendig aber
gebt euch das krass so ist wirklich
krass hätte ich nicht gedacht dass der
unterschied so heftig ist also dass ich
wirklich aus wie zwei völlig
verschiedene früchte zumindest vom alter
ja aber ich würde mal sagen das ist noch
nicht ganz so spektakulär
wir machen weiter mit dem typischen ich
wahrscheinlich auch die meisten bereue
ich habe ich auch glaube ich schon mal
im fernsehen gesehen
von flex werbung ich meine wer kennt es
nicht die milch tröpfelt du in das
cornflakes glas und dass die zwei mäßig
echt so lecker aus aber das ding ist das
geht gar nicht also milch kann das nicht
milch sieht nicht so aus wie in der
werbe- und fließt so völlig cremig
langsam aus der milchpackung das was ihr
da immer sehen ist kleber um genau zu
sein so weiß kleber oder leim kann man
glaube ich aufnehme hoffe ich mal also
ja so sollte es ja eigentlich original
aussehen tut es aber nicht weiß ich ich
finde sowieso so komplex brühl finde ich
sie gar nicht mehr so appetitlich aus
jetzt machen wir mal folgenden test hier
habe ich ein bisschen kleber geholt
natürlich verwenden die für so was dann
noch deutlich mehr kleber der auch so
wirklich runter fließt aber stellt euch
das einfach in der zehnfachen menge vor
leider haben wir auch noch eine zweite
stufe die muss ich auch noch kurz rein
ball an sommer sorry wenn du das siehst
es kann gut sein dass diese schale
danach im rat ist ich kaufe dir nur neue
aber was tut man nicht alles für einen
guten club gar so also hier das original
die haben jetzt 120 gramm kleben und
jetzt passt mal auf ja
das ist schon mal ganz wichtig dass die
komplex nicht direkt zur untergehen
sondern wirklich praktisch ja so
obendrauf schwimmen und mit diesem
kleber produkt kann man halt in der
werbung dann viel viel besser arbeiten
als mit sowas kann hier auch verstehe
ich meine wer von euch fühlt sich hier
nicht darauf stützen und denken bargau
schön cornflakes mit cremiger milch aber
das hat nicht senken
[Musik]
also das ist glaube ich so der
bekannteste trick aber ich habe noch
welche vorbereitet da bin ich auch mal
gespannt was damit passieren als
nächstes habe ich ein trick vorbereitet
der wohl in jeder fernsehwerbung weil es
um birgit benutzt wird ich meine egal
wie scheiße das bier ist in jeder bier
werbung scheint dass bis zum
gehtnichtmehr also wirklich man hat so
richtig schön dicken schaum obendrauf
also ich hab mal zwei ganz normale biere
von denen ich das eine was ich gleich
nicht mit spülmittel vermische auf jeden
fall dann trinken werde ich mein geld
samstagabend das geht gleich auf jeden
fall noch auf die piste mal gucken
welchen kollegen ich dann das bier
andrea wo halt so ein bisschen viel drin
ist also so sieht es aus wenn man wir in
ein glas schüttet ich muss sagen das
scheint jetzt auch schon ziemlich dollar
das problem ist nur das ist ja nach
einer minute wieder weg für die
produzenten der werbung weil ich meine
müssen jeder jede minute ein neues bier
ein schütten damit man die ganze zeit
diesen schönen schau mir oben drauf hat
also wir tun hier mal so ein bisschen
brauereien auf jeden fall nicht zu viel
weil sonst schon das viel zu doll aber
das wollen wir ja nicht hoffentlich
werden wir jetzt gleich nicht laut aber
hier sieht man schon wisst ihr was ich
meine
das sieht ja schon gar nicht mehr so aus
wie es eigentlich aussehen soll ja jetzt
bin ich selbst mal gespannt
ich glaube das war ein bisschen viel ja
kleinen moment gleich wieder da wir
nehmen diesmal wirklich nur ganz ganz
kleines bisschen ja mehr auch nicht
das ist auch alle warum schreibt auf den
sofas also wirklich nur ganz ganz ganz
ganz ganz ganz wenig nehmen und dann
läuft das schon da drüber momenten wir
warten jetzt einfach mal kurz ab aber
man kann ja schon einen ganz klaren
unterschied sehen hier haben wir
wirklich schauen bis zum umfallen und
hier ist er schon wieder weg also für
den trägt wirklich ganz ganz wichtig
dass wirklich nur einen tropfen
spülmittel rein sonst explodiert dass
hier fast und es muss ja auch noch bier
aussehen aber ich glaube hier dann kann
man auf jeden fall erkennen was ich
meine vor allem hier oben diese
schaumkronen zieht schon lecker so gut
ein hammer doch und zwar brauchen wir
dafür rasierschaum und sahne und zwar
kann man sich jetzt schon denken worum
es geht in der werbung wird keine sahne
benutzt wenn wirklich ein sahne produkt
vorgestellt wird sondern rasierschaum
nein
doch einfach was ihr schon viel länger
so bleibt wie er ist und sahne mit der
zeit halt irgendwie in sich
zusammenfällt das ganze zeigt euch
stimme anhand dieser beiden kekse wo man
sie vom 9
auf den einen keks kommen ganz normal
sagen sieht das leckere und auch mit
anderen kriegsschiffen bisher das hier
stellen
und jetzt warten wir einfach mal kurz
fünf minuten oder so ich würde auch
jetzt schon sagen der mit dem
rasierschaum sieht deutlich attraktiver
und leckere aus als dieser mit der sahne
die gleich zur seite runter gibt aber
wie gesagt wartet fünf minuten oder dann
haben wir dann im endergebnis wird es
gleich so leute fünf minuten sind rum
das ergebnis ist wirklich heftig schaut
euch das mal an wir haben hier einmal
den mit sahne und dann einmal den mit
rasierschaum und damit rasiert haben
sieht aus wie vorher damit seine
überhaupt dich also da kann man dann
wirklich sehen warum man das in der
werbung so macht ist ja nicht dumm man
kann dann halt nur die wissen sie das
produkt jetzt wirklich so aus oder was
haben die da rein gemischte ansonsten
was das jetzt mit dem ersten part ich
hoffe natürlich der hat euch gefallen
wenn ihr sagt alex macht auf jeden fall
noch ein paar dann lässt man doch nach
oben da ich würde auch sagen es gibt
noch sachen die sind viel viel krasser
als diese jetzt das waren sowieso staat
sachen die man schneller umsetzen kann
ich habe auf jeden fall noch einige
sachen rausgesucht die ich euch gerne
zeigen würde und dann würde ich sagen
sehen wir uns nächste woche mit einem
weiteren part wieder wie gesagt ich
hoffe ihr bock drauf checkt man
instagram ab da gibt es jetzt die
nächsten 365 tage jeden tag ein post ich
hoffe ihr folgt wieder wenn jetzt noch
nicht macht macht das gerne und das war
es von mir ich gehe es auf die piste
jetzt weiß ich gar nicht mehr bei sbb
ist mir das mit spülmittel war das hier
bei uns ich bin schon 16 wollte ich noch
anfügen
ich habe noch nie vor in irgendein video
alkohol getrunken ich hoffe ich hier
jetzt kein held dafür manchmal dringlich
auch alkohol aber nie zu viel